There's only one team left, they haven't
come yet Leo and Kokugami No, they'll definitely come We're
not the humans who will end here Then
enter the last 7th clear team
[Music] There's
still one more person left The last one  That
's all for Sanji's
selection. Why aren't we together?
Well, it's
over, I sent him to hell cleanly
Well, he certainly had a good physique, and his heart was
straight,
pure, righteous, and beautiful Just on the field, it doesn't matter if he's a good guy or not It
doesn't matter, it's a
momentary explosion  People who can't live for themselves are trash That innocent and
serious [ __ ] hero did
n't even raise my level in my life He was a
slime It doesn't matter what you do in Kunigami, so it does
n't matter Your
story  What the hell is this
guy?